these guys Andrew McDonald he was
calling John Hodge the writer or tell
you about in a second who featured in
that film and roll trance as well
they were look they got the screenplay
called shallow grave and they were
looking for a director they got money
off channel for 1 million pounds and all
he had to do was find a director and you
know find a decent cast and they sent it
out to about 20 directors and I went in
I read it and I immediately responded to
it saying you know it's the best script
I'd read in ages it was the most
exhilarating script because it just
wasn't mess about you know there was not
pages of description it was just this
incredible dialogue between these people
and as you and I it was lovely hearing
some of it again you and McGregor doing
some of that dialogue it's just like
fantastic anyway so I went in for the
meeting with them and I was very honest
and I said it's totally ripped off from
Blood Simple and I'm well done for doing
that because that's a great movie and of
course they didn't really want to ignore
that but of course it is you know it's
very very much indebted to the coin
brothers absolutely and and I said that
and I said we can improve it by doing
this and I'd always worked very
collaboratively naturally and I think
they really welcome that because they I
think there's fear was they would be
taken over by a director who would
change the script and make it into
something that they didn't want it to be
and we worked very collaboratively on it
where a million quid we our star was
Carey Fox who actually at the time was
the only one of them who was known
because she'd been in an amazing Jane
Campion thing called angel at my table
and she was like on the art circuit she
was a star at the time and she was the
one that guarantee does the money
because Channel four if we had her in it
and she'd been in mr. Oz virgin she'd
pledged one of the girls in there
because I've always loved her as an
actress and then we got these other two
guys who nobody knew about you and
McGregor who once it went on to be
obi-wan Kenobi and Chris Eccleston who
went on to be Doctor Who at one point so
we had we left leave you know we had two
Masters of the Universe in the future
Masters of the Universe in the shelter a
lot lots of things we seriously we had a
million quid and we've made it on
celluloid obviously because you know as
you could see by the telephones it was a
different era and
there were computers but they were
strange big fat things that sat in
offices and stuff like that so it was
just from a different ear but we had a
million quid and we ran out of money we
spent we spent all our money on the SATs
which to the flat you know and we spent
all the money on that and we ran out of
money by the end we had no money
the police scenes were the policemen
come to interview them they were all
done right at the end of the movie on
the last day and we'd no money left and
so we sold off bits of the set and bits
of the furniture because it's pretty
cool furniture so we sold it off to
members of the crew in order to buy more
celluloid because we know we know film
stock left and nobody would give us any
more money channel 4 said now forget it
it's just that and and it's interesting
watching it again that scene at the end
in the mortuary when he gets pushed
inside the mortuary that's a real
mortuary and there were real bodies in
there dead bodies and Chris Eccleston he
went on to be a future master of the
universe said I can't do this no I can't
go in there if there's dead bodies in
there so we so we had a bit of a crisis
and eventually we agreed that we'd put
one of the prop guys in there so that
when the door is closed and it goes dark
he wouldn't be alone with the dead
there'll be something else and in fact
you couldn't hear it very well you can
hear on the soundtrack this guy going
when the door closes and the lights go
off you can hear this guy going it's all
right Chris it's all right really
quietly I swear to god that's the truth